for decade hardcore users like
programmers engineers and attack
enthusiasts have not only been using
Linux themselves but they've been
preaching about why it's way better than
Windows and Mac so if Linux truly is the
objectively better OS why does no one
use Linux while Linux may be superior in
certain use cases almost all of these
use cases are professional they involve
databases networks and cloud computing
which are all things that the average
person will never deal with from the
back end also even amongst the people
who do use Linux for professional
purposes I bet most of them have a
Windows or Mac machine at home for
personal use cases